ahora vamos a cablear nuestro
controlador de motor l 298 lo ponemos
encima de la cámara en el lugar en donde
normalmente irían las baterías para
comenzar vamos a cubrir con cinta
aislante el lugar donde pondremos la
tarjeta del controlador del motor esto
nos sirve para dos cosas protege la
tarjeta de cualquier rayón provocado por
la parte de abajo de nuestro l 298 y
también nos permitirá retirar el l 298
cuando queramos ya que lo pegaremos con
silicón caliente vamos a quitar nuestro
arduino ya que nos estorba para colocar
los cables pegamos los cables de control
de nuestra cámara son los cables de
energía y de disparo de la cámara ahora
pasamos los cables de nuestro
interruptor de encendido hacia donde se
conectarán en nuestro controlador del
motor los pasamos por debajo de la
tarjeta de la cámara nos ayudamos con
las pinzas de nariz de aguja para jalar
suavemente los cables
hacemos lo mismo con los cables de la
batería aquí hay que tener cuidado de no
desprender alguno de los componentes que
ya teníamos colocados en el circuito de
la cámara cuando pasamos los cables por
debajo lo hacemos así para que nuestro
trabajo se vea mejor acomodado y limpio
aquí estoy cubriendo los extremos del
capacitor de la cámara ya que el l 298
tiene abajo algunas conexiones de metal
que podrían tocar los extremos del
capacitor y ocasionar un cortocircuito
para asegurarnos de que esto no suceda
vamos a cubrir todo esto con la cinta
negra aislante y verificamos la posición
de nuestro l 298
ahora lo que hacemos es tomar nuestra
pistola de silicón caliente y ponemos
unos dos centímetros de diámetro de
silicón caliente lo dejamos así unos
segundos 10 o 15 segundos y esto es para
que se enfríe un poco el silicón cuando
enfría se pone un poco más rígido y nos
proporcionará mayor acolchonamiento
entre la cámara y la parte de abajo del
l 298 cuando lo instalemos
ponemos el l 298 donde debe ir y lo
dejamos estar un tiempo y después
regresaremos a cablear lo el controlador
tardará en secar unos dos minutos ya
está rígido y en su lugar así que ahora
que ya está asegurado nuestro el 298
vamos a pelar los extremos de los cables
de nuestros motores y ya que los pelamos
vamos a ponerlos en las terminales de
motores del controlador pueden ver que
empujó cada cable en su pin y ahora
vamos a apretar los tornillos de nuestra
terminal y es así como cable amos
nuestros motores cada motor tiene dos
cables y cada par de cables va en uno de
estos bloques de motor
aquí conectamos el último cable del
motor del otro lado y lo aseguramos
ahora vamos a colocar los cables que van
a ir de nuestro arduino al controlador
del motor para indicar la dirección y
rapidez de cada uno de ellos hay varias
etiquetas en los diferentes canales de
entrada pueden ver que el primero dice
l1 y l2 a su lado l1 y l2 son cables
individuales que se conectarán al
arduino lo mismo va para l3 y l4 son
cables individuales que irán al arduino
hay otro diagrama junto al bloque
terminal que es 1 y 2 vamos a conectar y
1 y 2 con y 3 y 4 esto vamos a hacerlo
con cables cortos pelamos una parte de
estos cables y vamos a unirlos surgiendo
estos extremos para conectarlos y así
creamos un puente y vamos a conectar y 1
y 2 con y 3 y 4
ahora vamos a soldar el puente y lo
hacemos calentando el cable que está
alrededor del otro y conforme los cables
se calientan van a derretir la soldadura
y esta se esparcirá en la unión como
pueden ver aquí lo que formará una buena
conexión que no se desprenderá ahora
forramos con un poco de tubo de plástico
que se encoge con el calor y usamos
nuestra pistola de aire caliente para
que se encoja y lo cubra perfectamente y
así evitar que suceda algún
cortocircuito con nuestra conexión
esperamos a que el plástico se enfríe y
cortamos un poquito el exceso de cable
tomamos nuestro puente y conectamos y 1
y 2 y 3 y 4 que son los pines que faltan
vemos que el puente es un poco largo y
lo cortamos para ajustarlo mejor y
pegamos un poco el nuevo extremo para
poder insertarlo en donde corresponde
no es fácil quitar el aislante cuando el
cable es tan corto así que usamos
nuestras pinzas de corte para esto
ahora hacemos nuestras conexiones para
unir y 1 y 2 y 3 y 4 a veces es difícil
calcular la cantidad de cable que vamos
a necesitar para estas conexiones cortas
aunque no queremos que sobre mucho
porque sería fácil jalarlo y desconectar
vamos a acomodar los cables que salen
debemos tener 5 cables que salen vamos a
tratar de ponerlos juntos hacia abajo en
orden pero antes de hacer esto vamos a
cortar el exceso de cables
los alineamos juntos y paralelos para
que ninguno de los cables quede encima
de otro los dejamos bien alineados y
formados y después los pegamos hacia
abajo con nuestra cinta negra aislante
para mantenerlos en su lugar queremos
que sobresalgan los cables una pulgada o
2.5 centímetros por encima del anillo de
plástico para poder conectarlos con
nuestro arduino